[Music]
straight ahead online crime daily
r kelly's former runner says he drove
young girls on the singer's behalf the
obligations of keeping teenagers
confined to rooms on r kelly's property
the girls being forced to ask for
permission to eat but fans of the
courthouse standing behind him he didn't
do this
he needed to be set free
requests denied the major league pitcher
accused of beating and bruising a woman
her order of protection now dissolved
against trevor bauer the allegation is
they consented to this rough sex so what
do you do
is robert durst regretting sitting down
for the hbo series the jinx how the real
estate heirs interview is now impacting
his murder trial i lied to angel
repeatedly law and crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin day three of testimony in the r
kelly trial the singer's former runner
is now telling a federal jury girls who
looked really young were driven around
and kept locked up on r kelly's request
anthony navarro says that they worked
for that he worked for taylor swift
jay-z and kanye but working for r kelly
was quote weird a weird time for him
said things you had to do was a bit
uncomfortable and that the music part
was good but once he walked past the
gates it was the twilight zone a
different world he spoke about
transporting girls who looked really
young to and from the home and picking
out valtrex at the pharmacy on
medication for herpes on cross he spoke
about not seeing physical abuse but saw
verbal abuse that r kelly worked long
hours and explained how doors did not
have locks and some rooms had bathrooms
and that he heard females call r kelly
daddy terry the prosecution also brought
in our kelly's former doctor chris
mcgrath they spent a great deal on the
of time questioning him about r kelly's
herpes infections do you think they were
able to establish that r kelly knowingly
transmitted the disease
to your sexual partners
you know it's going to be a question of
timing here mcgrath treated kelly since
1984 and he suspected as early as 2000
that kelly might just have herpes and he
told kelly at that time to inform his
partners the public health law requires
disclosure of that information so that's
why that's important but documentation
for these prescriptions really didn't
start until march 2007 and the
documentation of his history of having
herpes didn't start until 2011. so
there's going to be some question as far
as the prosecution is concerned as to
whether or not they can show beyond a
reasonable doubt that kelly knew he had
herpes and that he was knowingly
infecting his partners that's the
question yeah it's going to come down i
think at least the most part to the
credibility of those witnesses
testifying because the question is did
he inform them of that or did he do it
without telling them and so that's going
to be something for the jury to decide
absolutely now r kelly's fans are known
for standing by him and one woman is
leading a group of supporters in front
of the courthouse throughout the trial
i've been a fan of r kelly since 1996 i
was listening to his music
and from i was living overseas and i
came here i've been living here for 22
years
and i've been a supporter of r kelly for
all these years and i know that r kelly
is an innocent man and all these ladies
that make false allegations against him
um they are they're lying
are fake and all of them saying the same
story because i get to understand that
all of them is communicating together
and they fix the stories together
let's bring in our guest judge susan
chris your honor listening to the
defense they weren't really denying uh
there was sex or the age of the girls
because there were some freudian slips
there at times
just that they lied about their age and
embellished about certain rules does
that sound like during nullification to
you and do you think it will work
it does sound like jury nullification
and i don't think it will work ignorance
of the law is not an excuse
in some cases where maybe there was a
small age difference and the girl really
really was older and sophisticated in
some fast situations even though it's
not an excuse a jury might feel sorry
for the guy and go along with it but not
in this situation where there's such a
disparity not only in age but in power
and control and the number of girls this
is not not a good defense
yeah i think that point that you made is
very important power and control it's
one thing to say hey i went to a bar and
they're supposed to id someone and i
went home with that person but it's very
different to have
girls as they are were transported back
and forth terry outside the court there
were many r kelly supporters often
dancing to his music
inside the court do you think jurors
will struggle to separate the man from
the musician
it could very well be a struggle but the
evidence against kelly is overwhelming
there are multiple victims and these
victims have encounters that took place
over a number of years very similar
accusations but i do think his fans and
that could include some of the jury will
think about the fact that this is a
legend he won three grammy awards just
for the song i believe i can fly he
certainly was billboard's most
successful artist for multiple years for
almost a decade and it is a fact that
you know he is going to be hard to
separate him as a person and him as a
legend so i think hopefully the jury is
going to be able to
barely consider the evidence and make
sure they apply the law like the judge
is telling them to do that's the
important part yeah and let's talk about
the law a little because the defense
terry did talk about this not being an
enterprise not being an organization
speaking more about the rico charges
against r kelly that his employees are
not feeding him women what do you think
about that distinction the defense is
trying to make in this case
you know i think that the defense is
going to lose on that it is a creative
claim the ricoh claim is something that
we haven't seen in this type of case
we've seen it with mafia cases but i
think they have all of the elements the
enterprise is of course kelly and his
organization the runners are the
different people in that enterprise so i
think it could succeed yeah it's
interesting they're starting to bring up
those witnesses to connect those dots in
this enterprise of course we'll keep
looking at that to help you connect the
dots in this the usbr kelly trial
turning now to more top legal news
britney spears has found herself under
investigation the pop star is accused of
striking one of her employees
according to the ventura county
sheriff's office one of britney spears's
employees says she was hit during a
dispute someone who works for the pop
star called authorities on monday
evening tmz is reporting spears
allegedly slapped a housekeeper's phone
out of her hands the sheriff's office
says no one was injured britney spears
attorney is responding to the allegation
calling an overblown sensational tabloid
fodder the investigation into the
incident is expected to be completed
shortly
still ahead on law and crime daily
shocking new allegations against the
accused kenosha shooter kyle rinhaus but
first the mlb pitcher scoring a legal
win why a judge rejected a permanent
restraining order request from a woman
who says trevor bauer beat her our legal
analysis next
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back a judge in california
denies a woman's request for a permanent
restraining order after her she claimed
a dodger's pitcher left her seriously
injured after sex
law and crime's angela levy is here with
what the judge said about the
allegations against trevor bauer
brian the accuser who we are not
identifying claimed that trevor bauer
left her with black eyes injuries to her
head and to her genital area but from
the very beginning trevor bower said all
of this was consensual
he's on administrative leave but la
dodger's pitcher trevor bauer gets a win
off the mound as a los angeles county
judge denied a woman's request for a
permanent restraining order against him
the woman's injuries were caused during
so-called rough sex between bauer and
her on two occasions last spring judge
diana gold saltman called photos of the
woman's injuries terrible but in denying
the request for a restraining order said
if she set limits and he exceeded them
this case would have been clear but she
set limits without considering all the
consequences and respondent did not
exceed limits that the petitioner set
law and crime legal analyst gene rossi
there was not enough evidence presented
to this judge
that in the future especially five years
down the road mr bauer would pose such a
grave threat
that they need a protective order to
protect the victim's
welfare and her life the 27 year old
accuser testified against bauer over
three days admitting she had battled
alcoholism but bower's team produced
text messages in which the woman had
asked bauer to choke her out and quote
gimme all the pain bower pleaded the
fifth refusing to answer questions the
accuser included instagram messages
between her and bower in her request for
a restraining order in which he wrote i
feel so bad that this happened wish i
could be there with you through it to
which she responded just grateful that
you are showing you care
bower then sent a yoda gift captioned me
trying to use the force to heal you
after hearing three days of testimony
the judge also dissolved a temporary
restraining order against bauer and
pasadena police are investigating
whether criminal charges should be filed
if they can't even get a protective
order
i think we have serious litigation risks
if we try to go criminal where the
burden of proof is much higher
i contacted police in pasadena
california and they told me that they
have no new information to share about
the investigation meanwhile trevor
bowers lawyers said that they expected
this request for the permanent
restraining order to be denied and they
were pleased with the judge's decision
bower remains on administrative leave by
major league baseball as an
investigation by that organization
continues
brian thanks angelette let's bring back
judge chris and terry austin terry do
you think there was a victim blaming
situation here or was it necessary to
consider the victim's intent in this
case
brian i think this is a very unusual
case it's the first time i've seen
something quite like this in most sexual
assault cases consent is really not an
issue the victim is claiming that there
was no consent at all whatsoever but
here with these two sexual encounters
there was some degree of consent by the
victim and the judge did conclude as
angenette said
that the woman set the limits and that
the respondent did not exceed those
limits so for that reason there was no
further restraining order imposed but
you know i think so there had to be a
discussion about this and i think that
the fact that she quote-unquote asked
for it had to be discussed it sounds
harsh it sounds terrible but it's part
of the case here and you know the whole
point is that you understand the need to
have that discussion when consent is
given at least for most of what occurred
here
absolutely and to gene rossi's point the
level for which you can get a
restraining order is so low it kind of
makes you think they might not be
criminal charges here but your honor you
heard the words of the judge in her
ruling about the limits and exceeding
them and and that they weren't exceeded
what did you think about how the judge
responded to this restraining order well
there's a much different burden
conjunction than a temporary injunction
so that's
but as as the other commentator said
there's a much higher one for a criminal
case i think this is this is so this is
unusual and yet if you think about 50
shades of grey this is what 50 shades of
grey is about it seems so weird
that you would have a contract so to
speak
that allowed pain that you're consenting
to pain but some people do and some
people do like that and i think the
judge is kind of struggling with
how do you fashion a remedy
to protect someone
from themselves and their own
efforts to
get this done to them
this is i think it's a victim shaming
here and i think the judge is just kind
of struggling with that and maybe second
guessing herself a little bit which may
not be a bad it's not always a bad thing
for judges to second guess themselves
agreed and did another woman make
similar claims against trevor bauer
yeah actually the washington post had a
story recently that reported that a
woman in ohio had filed for a temporary
restraining order against trevor bauer
last year for an incident that happened
a few years ago or a couple of incidents
but then that the woman dismissed that
restraining order on her own several
weeks later after bauer threatened legal
action with his lawyers so um that
protection order was never really in
effect for very long and bauer had also
considered that relationship or called
that relationship consensual he had
written about it on twitter and
apparently that woman is now cooperating
according to the washington post with
the major league baseball investigation
which is ongoing i did reach out to that
woman's lawyer and he did not return my
request for comment right we've got two
investigations going on we'll make sure
to give you those updates as they come
in thank you all coming up on law and
crime daily the investigative journalist
speaking out about jeffrey epstein and
the upcoming trial for his former madam
plus the shocking new video
investigators say they have of kyle
rittenhouse what the accused kenosha
shooter allegedly said just says he's
accused of killing two people after the
break
[Music]
welcome back we return with updates from
the accused kenosha shooter and new
evidence the prosecution wants to
present
cal rinhouse is accused of shooting and
killing two unarmed men and injuring a
third during a black lives matter
protest in kenosha wisconsin
prosecutors now say renton house is seen
on video from last summer wishing he had
his ar-15 as he watches a black man
jogging out of a pharmacy in the video
that was taken about two weeks before
the shooting ringhouse allegedly says
i'd start shooting rounds at them
prosecutors say the 17-year-old's desire
to shoot people is doubly relevant in
the upcoming trial where the defense
will try to claim self-defense rent
house's trial is set to start november
1st
prosecutors for jeffrey epstein's madame
gelaine maxwell are asking a judge to
withhold the names of her uncharged
co-conspirators maxwell is expected to
stand trial in november and federal
prosecutors are now indicating they
won't be shining a spotlight on other
people accused of aiding and betting
epstein in court documents prosecutors
say they only plan to introduce
statements by epstein himself and an
employee that scheduled his massage
appointments law and crimes managing
editor adam classfeld spoke with julie k
brown a journalist for the miami herald
and author of perversion of justice on
the latest episode of his podcast
objections
what epstein and his uh co-conspirators
did
was it was not a transactional
sexual uh arrangement it wasn't like i'm
going to pay you 200 for sex
he used fraud and coercion to get these
girls to do this he did not tell them
what was really going to happen he he
used other girls to lure them in and he
basically they used the the spiel that
he was going to get they were only being
hired to give him a massage
so to characterize this even back then
when it was legal for a minor to have
sex you know for money to characterize
this as prostitution was totally wrong
from the beginning
when we come back robert durst seventh
day on the stand how can we tell facts
from free fiction what the prosecutor is
doing to call durs out on what he thinks
are lies next
[Music]
welcome back we look to california where
robert durris is still on the stand
after seven days of questioning three in
cross-examination
the real estate air is on trial for the
murder of his best friend susan berman
durst has also been previously accused
of murdering his first wife kathy after
her disappearance in 1982. shortly
before she vanished durst started a
relationship with prudence pharaoh
sister to actor mia farrow and the
inspiration for the beatles songs dear
prudence one question about his affair
durst says that it was resolved once
kathy went missing
kathy knew what i was saying prudence
by seeing prudence meaning you were
sleeping with her correct
correct
you wanted to pursue a relationship with
prudence by your own statement
kathy did not want you to pursue
a relationship with prudence and i'm
asking you how did that get resolved
yes he disappeared
durst has also testified to his tendency
to lie to officials not just in
interrogations or even on the stand but
also to the filmmakers and of the jinx
prosecutor lewin did not let this slide
on the third day you knew that was a lie
correct because you knew you had said
that to him the day before is that right
i lied to angel repeatedly
which
so which version were you lying on the
12th
or the 13th or both
oh
how are we supposed to figure out when
you're lying and when you're telling the
truth
i don't know
if you think of it let me know interrupt
me
the question is not does bob durst
remember what happened that night
the question is is bob durst being
truthful
about what he's saying do you understand
my question
how are you doing
okay can you answer it
i agree okay
it is rumored that durst employed his
best friend susan berman to call in sick
to kathy's rotation the day that she
went missing an accusation that durst
denies but is this also a lie
if
you had had kath and susan call dean
cooperman
and asked her to pretend to be kathy
durst
would you tell us
susan berman
never called albert einstein
or dr cooperman
pretending to be cathy
ejection non-responsive motion to strike
to their understanding of healing
i don't think he likes any of my
questions but
hi john
your honor you've had front row seats to
seeing robert durst testify he lies here
he lies there it seems like robert durst
lies everywhere so how can a jury find
anything he says credible
i don't think they can i think he's
gotten away with it before but this time
i think he's overplayed his hand
all right it seems like maybe he's met
the end or got to the end of his rope
when it comes to his lies and i think uh
i agree with lewin how do you believe
him if anything terry durst admitted
that the affair with prudence pharaoh
was resolved when kathy disappeared was
that a perry mason moment
i think this was definitely a perry
mason moment lewin went into great
details about the affair and it was a
long time affair but in december 1981
durst wanted to pursue that relationship
and kathy did not want him to pursue
that relationship then when lewin said
so how did that get resolved durst
walked right into the trap he said well
kathy disappeared but we didn't hear on
that clip but what durst and lewin did
say after that was lewin said yes that
is how it got resolved and that was a
very good point all right will robert
durst talk himself into a conviction or
out of one we don't know but continue to
follow along crime thank you for joining
us here at longhorn daily we'll see you
next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
you